- I'm hanging all hour with the host
of the #IMOMSOHARD podcast
Jen and Kristin, give it up.
(audience cheers)
My next guest is an actress, model,
host of "So You Think You Can Dance?"
And of course, a mom.
Her new children's book
is called "The Joy in You"
and it's out right now.
Joining us all the way from London,
please welcome Cat Deeley everybody!
(smooth music)
(audience cheers)
First of all I love your lip color.
- You know what, I just
said to your producers,
is it too much?
Like--
- No!
- To me, this is such an
amazing occasion I've literally,
I've got a glass of champagne.
(Kelly laughs)
I've got my bottle.
Like literally, I get to hang out
with cool, funny, smart moms.
Like I haven't done this enough.
So for me, that's enough of an excuse
for a red lip.
- Oh I think--
Girl if I thought it was too much
I just wouldn't have talked about it.
I think it's awesome. (Kelly laughs)
I think it's beautiful.
- Thank you.
- Yes.
But Cat, tell us about
your new children's book.
I read to my children,
no kidding every night.
It's a huge thing in our household.
I'm assuming it was inspired
by your boys, right?
- Of course, course it was.
You know what, it's one of these things
that I'd always wanted to do.
It was a definitely an ambition.
And then it got to a point
where I was like okay,
like any other mom, I'm sure
you completely understand,
at the end of the night I am exhausted.
I put on my pajamas,
I can barely string a sentence together,
I'm completely inarticulate.
And at that moment I'm putting them to bed
and I'm like okay,
what do I want to say when
I can't find the words?
What feelings do I want my
children to go to bed with?
And I think it doesn't matter who you are
or what our background is,
or where you come from.
Essentially we all want the
same thing for our children,
which is to be happy and kind.
Everything else is great,
but we basically want that.
And we want them to be able
to talk about their emotions
and talk about their feelings.
And.
I feel that's how they
reach their full potential
as an adult.
So really it was all of those things.
It's feelings, emotions, thoughts,
and it's top and tailed with love.
And it's just how I want my
boys to go to bed at night.
- I love it.
I love the art as well.
(Jen cries)
I know.
(Kelly laughs)
We wanna read it too.
No the art is so beautifully
done, I love the illustration.
What do your kids think about the book?
Are they excited about it?
Like my girl didn't get it for a while
that it was named after her.
Like I have one and she
didn't get it for a while.
Now she thinks it's super cool.
But what do your kids think?
- Oh they didn't get it either.
Like you get at the end of the book
and he'd be like, why are you in the book?
- Why is your picture, yeah.
- They didn't, yes,
exactly the same thing.
Didn't get it at all.
And then sometimes he'll be,
Milo will be literally like hold my face,
and he'll do this thing where he holds it
and gives me a big smooch
and he goes "mom that
was a movie star kiss.
"It's so lovely, I love this book."
And then other times, obviously
because he's a four-year-old
it's slightly Jekyll and Hyde,
and you never really know
what you're gonna get right?
(Kelly laughs)
- Yes.
- You know that
feeling right?
- Yes, amen.
- And so the one night he says to me,
"mom" and he's a bit like
a teenager at this point.
"Mom, you know your book
it says I can do anything,"
and I says "yes Milo you can
"if you put your mind to something
"and you find something you love
"and you wanna work hard, you
can do anything you wanna do."
And he's like "well
that's not true is it?"
- Oh no.
- And I was like, uh.
"Well what do you mean?"
He says, "well that's not true,
"because what I wanna do
"is I wanna take a
koala home from the zoo,
"bring it here and keep it as a pet.
"I can't do that can I mom?"
(audience laughs)
- He's very literal.
- And through my head I'm going,
Cat Deeley's kid kidnaps
koala and kills it from zoo,
you know like I'm thinking that.
And I'm like oh no no no no no no no no
you can't do that, you can't do that.
I said "but what you can do"
and you know in those,
and I'm sure we've all had those moments,
where you know when they ask you something
and your brain is like racing
trying to find the right answer.
And you can almost hear your brain work?
And it's like (Cat rolls tongue)
I mean it's almost like a drum roll
for when you come up with the answer.
And you're going as fast as you can.
And I said "no Milo you
absolutely can't do that."
I said "but what you can do,
"is if you go to school
and you study really hard
"and maybe you might study
something called biology.
"And then you can study
something called zoology
"and go to university.
"Then you could be in charge
of all the koalas at the zoo.
"Or you could even travel to
the other side of the planet,
"which is as far as you
can get to Australia,
"which is where koalas come from.
"And you could go to a sanctuary,
"and you could help koalas
who don't have a mom and dad.
"And you could feed them--"
- Great answer.
- And I just.
And I left it like that.
And in my head I was
like high fiving myself
and all the rest of it.
And he just looked at me like that.
(audience laughs)
- He's like, not the same.
- All right mom.
(Kelly laughs)
All right mom.
- I guess I'll accept that answer.
- Exactly.
- I love that.
I love how you twisted,
that was really really nice.
Well Cat's new book "The
Joy in You" is out now,
you'll have to get it.